hi
what i'm going to tell you about today
is that i actually think we're in real
trouble
that is i think we actually have the
foggiest idea how to compute very well
and i think that there are some small
you know glimmer of hope on the horizon
in a number of different directions
which i may point out
okay but i think most of the things
we've been talking about even here
are obsolete i thought what i said to uh
somebody
after the haskell session i went to
there was a workshop yesterday
is gee this is the most advanced of the
obsolete languages
okay and what i mean is this okay
see that you now see the triangle that
isn't there
right everybody see the triangle that
isn't there
good okay what did you do it took only
100 milliseconds or maybe 200
milliseconds
okay that means between your eyes and
whatever it is that knew it was 100
milliseconds certainly if you had to put
on brakes if you saw something like that
right and it was crossing the street
okay you know you know that's only if
you had to build that's only
a few tens of neuron times
i don't care how parallel the machine is
i have the foggiest idea how to write a
program
that organizes a complex process like
that in
a latency of about 30 or 40 steps
now that's that's an example of
something we don't understand how to do
okay and it's more serious than that
okay
a human genome is about a gigabyte
that's the instructions for making you
from a cell
okay it's you know your pre-complicated
machine
gigabytes about the same size as the
source code appropriate for
say making microsoft windows
right it's not much bigger or smaller
it's something like that
okay so yeah we have all the possible
things that it could possibly do and all
the
drivers that might be relevant and
everything it's probably that size it's
not can't be
it's not much bigger let's put it down
it's not three orders and i do bigger
and a gigabyte is a a gigabyte is
not that big but what's interesting is
that with a small change to it you make
a cow instead of a person
so it's flexible too
so we've got this enormously flexible
language there that we haven't the
foggiest idea of what it's like
i'm not talking about dna dna's you know
this that's
that's something like gates or something
okay what i'm interested in is the high
level language
that's necessary to do things like that
and we certainly don't know how to do
that
so now what can we say about that
well i'll tell you one little thing but
maybe there's some hints
you know these biologists do nasty
experiments on animals i suppose you
took a
uh salamander you know a salamander
can regrow its its limbs if you cut them
off so all these nasty biologists do
things like
they'll cuddle they'll cut a limb of the
salamander hand
the arm off over here at the show just
between the
the shoulder and the and the elbow and
the between and at the same time cut the
same one
between the uh elbow and the hand
flip around that segment and resew it
back on
nasty thing to do to the salamander but
what do you think you get
does anybody know is anybody here no
no you get the three elbows it grows two
new elbows
to make up for the fact that the that
the wrong thing is connected to the
wrong thing
okay it's pretty weird okay
but but there's a clue that's a clue to
something
that we should be thinking about about
how do you talk
about how to make a bazillion dollars
we're talking
humans like 10 to 12 cells okay a
salamander is probably 10 to the 11th or
10th to 10th i don't know
okay but the fact is that how do you
make a a how do you how do you
make that something big like that grow
itself the little neighbors talk to each
other
and they say oh boy you know this i'm
supposed to connect to a thing like this
but ain't there so we'll make some of
that
okay and that's the sort of amazing kind
of process
that's going to be necessary if we want
to approach the future in our computing
because by golly it's very it's almost
impossible to set up
a situation where we understand
everything that's going to happen in the
future
let me give you a get let go back in
past a bit
okay when i started computing in
1961 this was a this was
the computer this wasn't this particular
one but it was an ibm 650 at columbia
university that i was competing at
okay that machine cost a half a million
bucks
it was it had 2 000 decimal
2000 words of 10 decibel digits each
of memory on a drum that rotated
so the access time is 12.5 milliseconds
okay so they take a 10 milliseconds
cycle time
and that the total amount of memory is
probably about 10 kilobytes
now for the price of that machine i can
now buy 50 000 pcs
okay literally okay each with a gigabyte
of ram
that's what's it that's 10 to the fourth
times as much
and with uh uh and which were about a
million times faster
so one of the things has been happening
over the years
i'm not trying to worry about mr moore's
law anything like that
what i'm worried about is that all of
our
all of our sort of intuitions
from being programmers have come from a
time of assuming
a kind of scarcity
a world in which computation is
expensive
where memory is somehow expensive where
we have to optimize it
okay well there are some applications
like that
but the answer is most things are not
like that at all right now
memory is free computing is free
it's our problem now to figure out how
to use computing like that
and you know if i had 50 000 pcs hooked
up with an appropriate network which
would probably cost a million dollars at
that point
modern dollars okay well then you buy
them
in bulk uh by golly you know you could
make a pretty serious computer out of
that
that by this machine took 30 kilowatts
for the if you're interested
i have the power plug from the 1794
which was somewhat more advanced
but that's a different problem
okay so it is no longer necessary to
minimize operations
it is no longer necessary to worry about
to worry about how much memory we take
up it is very important to
minimize latency okay that's critical we
have to understand that
but the real cost of computation is not
that at all it's the cost of programmers
okay here's a uh a quote from mr
evans from glasgow made a while ago
it turns out that almost all the cluster
computing is you
and me okay that's a different world
that's the real problem okay so what are
we going to do
well there's lots of things people worry
about
over the years we hear lots of pundits
worrying about things
i know people worry about correctness
gee that's a problem is it the real
problem maybe
probably not most things don't have to
work
look at google if it makes a mistake it
doesn't matter
okay so long as the next time he gets
the right answer right or maybe
something nice or close to the right
answer something called reasonable
it needs a reasonable answer okay
uh what other kinds of things are there
well people worry about about security
well they've got no idea how to handle
security uh we'll find out for example
that uh humans managed to make it for
about 70 years
would be continuously attacked by
parasites
gee there must be some clever things
we're doing okay
it's all in that gigabyte of code
hey it's we've got to think about that
we don't we certainly haven't got any
any good ideas about how to make how to
make things that last for a very long
time when continuously attacked by
mutating parasites
okay that's okay right
okay the other thing that seems really
important to me
is that we spend all our time modifying
existing code
okay the problem is our code is not
adequately evolvable right
it's not adequately modifiable to fit
the future
in fact what we want is to make systems
that have the property
that they are good for things that the
designer didn't even think of or intend
that's a big problem okay that's the
real problem i want to go after today a
little bit
okay so what's the what is this problem
the problem is
that when we build systems whatever they
are
we program ourselves into holes i've
done it a number of times
i've been programming as i said since
1961 i found more ways to screw up than
anybody i know
okay and i've learned a lot of hope but
not an infinite amount
okay and let's say so here's the here's
this problem
okay how do we keep ourselves from from
programming ourselves into holes what is
the what does that mean it means that we
make decisions early in some process
that spread all over our system those
the consequences of those decisions
such that the things that we want to
change later
are very difficult to change because we
have to change a very large amount of
stuff
that's the problem okay and i want to
figure out ways that we can
organize systems so that the
consequences of decisions we make are
not
expensive to change we can't avoid
making decisions
but we can try to figure out ways to
minimize the cost
of the of of changing decisions we've
made
okay so let me start with a simple a
simple example
one that is so familiar that we all do
it these days certainly in in
good in good dynamically uh typed
languages
like lisp or python or whatever or in in
good statically typed languages like
haskell or whatever
okay we always have something like
generic operators they call it operator
overloading
and things like that okay let's talk
about that for a second because
i'm going to be very extreme about this
okay
here's a here's the traditional
arithmetic you would find in scheme
okay i can add integers together great i
can add introduce to rationals
i can make new rationals i can add
introduce to
quote reels okay they're of course
floating point
thingies that are very dangerous
nothing brings fear to my part more than
a floating point number
i mean
numerical analysis the blackest art i
know and you know they just without
worrying about this it's terrible
but then again but we can deal with
things like complex numbers and
and exact complex numbers which are
integer parts
and things like that and that's okay
okay
but you know those things are built in
okay how about dynamically extensible
generic operations now we can do that of
course
if you do a separate compile time and
interpretive time or run time
something weird is happening here and i
want to be able to dynamically extend
things while my program is running i
want a program to compute up what it's
going to do
okay remember in the old days when you
used to program an assembly language or
something
at least i used to do that yeah it's a
great language because
you could write the next instruction
you're going to execute
you could put it into the place where it
was you were going to go to it just was
and you know that many interesting
programs were written that way and it
was very flexible
there's too many fearful people you know
i can see a lot of people cringing
but the fact is that you know you could
do that lisp also
okay you can eval something you call it
concept okay that's
boy is that useful but in any case okay
so here i have i can do things like
expand this arithmetic on functions you
know
here's an example i can add together
sine and square right over there
okay and i've got a new function because
that's a
classical thing people can do in algebra
or in in
mathematics you say if you've got two
functions with the same kind of input
then they can they can the sum of those
is in fact
assumed to be the sum of the outputs
okay it's a as it's a generic extension
okay that is for things that are of type
procedure if you want
of the right same the same number
arguments i could talk about
the sum of the square oops of of uh sine
and cosine
applied to 2.5 and i got one that's
right that's what i should expect
okay good okay that's an example of a
simple extension
there's gonna be seven and by golly you
know you have all these nice things i'm
looking at watching
uh somebody talking about scala z today
and of course you can do things like
that
okay but you then you get to things with
let's start things better
there's symbolic algebra okay now this
is a symbol this is a
again a generic extension i'm going to
explain how it works
except that i can tell addition and
subtraction multiplication division all
those things
to deal with symbolic entities as well
literal numbers
okay and what i get is a symbolic
expression as a result of such
computation okay and i can of course the
nice thing is that's a fragment of a
program that came out
so i could write a program that writes a
program and i can use it
i'll tell you a good example of the use
of that okay it's a numerical analysis
example
build a gear integrator does everybody
know what a gear integrator is anybody
know what a gear integrator is
it's for something called stiff
equations differential equations okay
turns out there's some polynomials that
you have to compute up and if you
compute
about ahead of time you only can do you
know having a step or doubling the step
size
but if you want to be able to make the
step size any size you want you want to
be able to compute up the appropriate
polynomial at the moment
so you write a thing that symbolically
does that then you pass that through the
compiler as you need it
and then you you run it and use it in
the same program that's sitting wrong
integrating along
turns out it's a great great thing to do
and great fun
okay but the point is that you can get
essentially machine level
machine quality code you know you're
getting fully fully uh
fully native code efficiency except at
the moment where you're changing step
size to a financial step size
okay that's a useful thing that's why i
like list because it has uniform
representation of programs as data so
that symbolic manipulations produce
stuff that i can execute okay now
but you know you could do something even
more wild you could did you know that
automatic differentiation does that
everybody know what differentiation
functions is
and automatic differentiation can be
done as a as a
generic extension what you do is you
create hyper real numbers
numbers that look like x plus delta x
the same way the complex number
is real part plus uh j times the
imaginary part of i if you're a
mathematician
j if you're an electrical engineer
that's because of a french
invented use j for user i for intensity
which is current
but in any case in any case uh there's a
you could do this sort of thing okay and
you could say the derivative of the
cosine and the sum of the cosine the
square function
applied to x is now i'm using of course
my symbolic parts as well
so these things all mixed together okay
this is the uh
sum of two x and minus sine x so two x
minus sine x
okay and i can you know i can look at
something more complicated
a derivative of a function of two
variables which is in fact a structure
of the two partial derivatives which is
what it should be because if i multiply
that
by an increment in the incr the
arguments i should get an increment in
the answer
and that's a matrix multiplication this
is you get a row vector coming out
okay that's the sort of thing that you
can do very easily of course i'll tell
you the trick of how to do this
okay just for fun okay for those of you
who are interested in things like this
kind of trick
this is the kind of thing you're
interested in so if you have
if you take every possible that was it
that was pulled out of
abraham lincoln actually used that that
uh comment
uh if you have a if you if you
extend things x plus dx and you have all
your primitive functions
including things like addition
subtraction multiplication division okay
and things like that
now are tanned with two arguments and
things like that produce an output which
is
f of x plus d of f x times dx where dx
is the
thing that corresponds in the that's uh
the imaginary unit
in imaginary numbers okay then you can
then
then what you can do is you can just
push things through that and extract out
the df of the df which is the derivative
of the function
okay now that gets you the chain rule
instantly and automatically
right that's it so you do a generic
extension of all your
primitive operations and you get the
automatic chain rule which is right and
that's hard to do symbolically without
any other way
but this works also numerically at full
speed
whatever you want okay it's producing
it's producing a
composition in the same way you have
combinators
okay so that's a useful kind of thing
and
i actually use this all the time because
i teach a class in fact i'm teaching one
this term
in advance advanced classical mechanics
starts with lebron's equations and goes
through canonical perturbation theory
and i use computer programming in my
class and to
for these graduate students of physics
and things like that use computer
programming
in this class to actually clarify
the things we put right on you know when
we write down these equations
because mathematical notation is both
awful and it turns out ambiguous
and to be perfectly honest it's into
it's impressionistic
right it's very simple it's look what
i'm talking to you in english it's the
same phenomenon mathematicians talk to
each other because they're almost all
alike that's the way reason why you can
understand me is almost all identical
okay and so there's only a few bits have
to be transferred in order to get an
idea across
maybe a mathematician's painting an idea
in the platonic world
of another mathematician's mind okay by
talking to them they write down
basically uh impressionistic scribbles
the same way
my speech is not grammatical beautiful
english okay but in fact
uh when we when we write programs we
have to be
precise because computers are dumb at
this point and as a consequence that's a
great way to show someone the real story
okay and so i can write things like this
which is the definition of
of the method of computing lebron
equations right here from a lagrangian
given a configuration space path now for
those of you who don't know this sort of
thing doesn't matter
i'm not going to dwell on it but what
this basically is is you make a
state path out of a configuration space
path which is a tuple
of three things the time the uh the path
the path value at that time
and the derivative of the path out of
the velocities okay and you have to take
the
the derivative with respect to the time
which is the capital d here
because that's derivative one argument
of the result of getting the partial
derivative respect to the
the the uh velocity argument of the
lagrangian
uh and you'll compose that with the
state path et cetera
okay and you get the right things here
and by golly if you take a harmonic
oscillator or whatever you like
you stuff in lagrange's equations and
out comes out comes the actual
residual which is equal to zero which is
lagrange's equations
okay nice okay now if you want that
doesn't matter for
what did i say but you know that's
yeah that's that's that's easy stuff
what if i had to do something with them
no i need it what if i deal with what if
i'm dealing with something
with the with a couple of rigid bodies
that are that are wobbly and have wall
sensors
then i can't write the equations down on
this on this board okay
in fact it's something if you do
celestial mechanics like i've done
sometimes the equations are 20 pages
long
okay and by golly it better be done by a
computer
you the old days people did it by hand
they got it right most of the time it
was amazing it's amazing i can't do what
what people did
in 1911 or whatever but it's quite
amazing that they could do that sort of
thing
and now we can do this easily and it
turns out that this is very simple
because of the simple generic extension
okay now i'm not trying to claim that
solves any important problem
okay very careful about that okay
that this is this is a little tiny
feeling
of what is it needed to make things more
flexible
consider the the value here the value is
that i'm dynamically allowed to change
the meaning of all my operators
to add new things that they can do
dynamically
not a compile time at run time okay i
can programs can produce things which
are the new way to add
okay that sort of stuff and they can
attach that to edition and they can take
it off and all that
and it can look like it can look like
binding i can bind that idea
okay that's wonderful okay what does it
do what it's doing it's giving me
tremendous flexibility
flexibility because the program i wrote
to run on on a bunch of numbers
with only a little bit of of tweaking
suddenly runs on suddenly runs on
matrices
so long as i didn't make the mistake of
commuting something wrong
okay if i did i'm in trouble right so
this makes proving the theorems about
things very hard
in fact maybe impossible
and that's the sort of cost the cost is
and the benefit
are are very extreme okay
i can pay i could pay correctness
okay or proofs of correctness or belief
in correctness
i can pay that for tremendous
flexibility
right there
now again we worry about ideas like is
correctness the essential thing i want
look i'm not opposed to proofs i love
prince i'm an old mathematician
okay the problem is that proofs
putting us into the situation that mr
dijkstra got us into
about 30 years ago 40 years ago where
you know you're supposed to prove
everything to be right before you write
the program
okay getting yourself into that
situation puts us into a world
where we have to make our specifications
for the parts as tight as possible
because it's hard to prove general
things except occasionally sometimes
easier
but usually it's harder to prove a
general theorem about a about something
so you make a very specialized thing
that works for a particular case
you build this very big tower of stuff
okay and boy is that brittle
change the problem a little and it all
falls over we didn't learn something
from the digital
from the fact the electrical engineering
i did the digital abstraction
whereby the inputs to something except
much bigger range than the outputs are
allowed to produce
and therefore you get rid of noise at
every stage
that's that's the kind of flexibility
that i i'm expecting to get
and i hope to get now remember the old
stuff you by the way when you do this
kind of generic thing
extensions it doesn't mean that the old
stuff breaks it means the new stuff is
not
is not proved got to be careful about
that
okay so with all many of the techniques
i'm advocating
make proof much more difficult and
perhaps impossible
now i'm going to now be a little more
extreme
i haven't been extreme yet this is this
is the beginning of stuff
okay i think one of the problems of the
is the kind of architecture we're
assuming
everything in the world is looks like at
least looks like my 650.
it's you know it's very occasionally
people have made wonderfully
things a gpu is different right
but maybe i suppose the connection
machine was an experiment
which was different okay but you know in
the future it's going to be the case
that
that computers are so cheap and so easy
to make
that you can make them the size of a
grain of sand complete with a megabyte
of ram
you're going to buy them by the but by
the
bushel i suppose you can pour them into
your concrete
okay you buy your concrete by a megaflop
and then you have a wall that's smart
okay so long as you can just get the
power to them and they could do
something
you know that's going to happen okay
it's sort of the way i said remember
your cells are about are pretty smart
they have about a gigabyte of
rom for a few a few a few bytes of ram
probably and or maybe a few hundred we
don't know how many but
and they but they seem to talk to each
other and do useful things
so we have to begin to worry about that
kind of a world
okay well i'm going to tell you a story
that started
um around 1975 okay
and was recently had a some advances
uh it's called propagators it started
when i was teaching my first classes in
electrical engineering at mit
uh in circuit theory actually actually
the first class i thought was the field
theory
but then i taught a circuit theory class
with a real wizard of circuit three
affect theory uh paul penfield
and i observed that what we taught the
students wasn't at all
what the students actually were expected
to learn
that is what an expert person did when
presented with a
circuit that looked like that was quite
different from what
uh what the we tell them to write down
the node equations and there are certain
equations for
the the resistor and the capacitors and
the and the inductors which are
none of them here and the transistor
which has a complicated non-linear
equation
and then you're supposed to grind these
equations together somehow and solve
them
to find out what's going on but you know
that's not what a per what a really a
really good
engineer does what a good engineer does
he looks at this thing says hmm
um uh well let's uh consider the bias
analysis here
that means these capacitors are open
circuits
okay and that means that um therefore
and
i'm going to consider this transistor to
be uh beta infinite
and be a follower right now meaning its
base
its base emitter uh voltage is going to
be 0.7 that's
an assumption based on the assumption of
how we're using it
it might actually be wrong which case i
might have to back out
of this okay given that there's no
there's no
current into the base here there's no
current going into this capacitor so
there's a voltage divider since i know
the voltage here and i know the voltage
here i know the volts here
therefore i know the voltage here this
point seven volts below that therefore i
know the voltage across this resistor so
i know the current through it that
current must be coming through
the from the collector here therefore it
must be going through this resistor
therefore it lowers this voltage by
amount which is
rc times the uh current which is
the voltage from here to here divided by
the resistance which is points et cetera
okay and so therefore i can tell you
therefore i can tell you
the the uh the the all the bias
conditions of this transistor
and i need to use that to check whether
or not my assumptions were right and
they are
okay now given that incrementally i can
tweak this
thing that means this capacitor is now
short circuit uh that means i tweak this
in voltage
which means this changes by the right
amount which means this current changes
by an amount which is the amount this
voltage change divided by that
resistance which means this voltage goes
down by an amount which this
which is the current uh increment
divided by multiplied by that resistance
so the gain of this stage as an
amplifier is rc over rtre
it's within five percent that's right
okay and every real engineer does that
okay and that's not the sort of thing
that we were teaching the students
so i wanted to figure out how to teach
students this sort of thing
right of course the right vision of
things is you write a program
and then give it to the students to read
okay that's
what i did is i actually hired richard
stallman in 1975 to work for me
and he and i wrote this program together
and it was quite a success
and i'll just i'll show you a modern
version of it because the old code
doesn't seem to exist anymore
i went looking for it and it was that
was on the old its operating system and
it's gone
and probably probably on some backup
tape somewhere which somebody has
it can be found but it's not around now
so here's a new version of the same
program
uh here's an example that here's the
representation of that amplifier
i'm not going to tell you what i'm not
going to read it to you okay
what it is it's a wiring diagram
guess what the same lambda calculus
combination
structure that you use for functions
works for
other kinds of things too all it is is a
consistent naming scheme
it says for example let rb1 be a
resistor
let um let the rail node be a particular
node combining a bunch of
terminals from the various parts that
were declared previously
and the outer scope uh and so i have a
bunch of nodes then i can say
uh i'm going to produce a few more
things and and that's my
the output of that is this rest of the
stuff okay wiring diagram description
description of how these things are put
together okay
that's a really nice thing remember
underneath this is lambda calculus
nothing more there's no magic in there
okay it's just
it's just naming as a very smart
mystic once said if you have the name of
the spirit you have power over it
so then once you do that then you can
then you can for example make a test a
test jig for this
which looks sort of like that okay and
i could tell it what kinds of uh what
kinds of parameters i want notice by the
way i'm allowed to use
uh i i get all my values are also
allowed to have
have units that's another generic
extension it doesn't matter
it's just simple once you have generic
operators you can make units and it
works just great
okay i can assume i can make various
other assumptions about
here's the transistor assumptions that
are pretty simple
i can say what what my assumptions are
for getting the thing on the
on the chalkboard here this is to make
the arguments short enough to put on one
on one slide okay and then i can ask
what's the value of
of the potential of the the base of the
amplifier in the bias region
and it does some deduction and it comes
out with an answer in volts
okay and then you say well it's the
value of the potential on the emitter
and you get the same kind of thing
uh not very interesting but the really
interesting thing is here
i can ask why
why do you believe mr computer why do
you believe that the potential on the
emitter of the amplifier in the bias
region
is what it is and out comes a out comes
the thing with a
remarkable qed that has nothing to do
with proving okay
it's just to be arrogant okay but what
what it's telling you is the because
remember almost all these things are
lies anyway
the models i told you for the transistor
a lie
all of all the physics and and and and
uh electrical engineering things like
that is based on
useful lies which are appropriate
approximations for particular jobs
okay and the reason why when galileo
invented
the modern physics for all practical
purposes what he just discovered was the
value of a lie
aristotle understood that when you roll
the ball along the floor it always
stopped
galileo said forget about the friction
let's figure it out and then put the
friction back in
that was a required lie to understand
what was really going on
that changed the world okay that was the
big breakthrough of galileo
okay so this qed doesn't mean anything
but what really matters is that i'm
chasing down the provenance of every of
every value
as the values move around in this thing
and what's really going on here
what's really going on is that i'm doing
what the
what the expert did i'm seeing something
very obvious
what i'm seeing is that if i know the
value here then i know the value here
because of a local phenomenon
okay i'm propagating information around
and if i know the value here and i know
the value here and i know this value
then i know that value
okay and that that propagates through
here into here
and so on okay so this is information is
propagating around
we call this propagators and that was a
that was a big idea in 1975.
okay however it does have some mind
some power okay the power is
this let's go back here
that we have imagine that the
propagators are independent little
stateful
stateful machines that observe that are
connected to a number of little things
i'll call cells
not biological okay so that a propagator
holds a bunch of
fingers on a bunch of cells given that
it it knows
information from this one and this one
and this one it may be able to deduce
the value there
and go clobber okay and given that that
value suddenly got changed
then this guy said oh i see something
interesting and it may go change that
guy
okay so there's a that information moves
around it's allowed to go in any
direction
right but that's so there are these
stateful cells that carry half state
okay and there are these interstates
propagating machines and guess what
this is very nice for a very parallel
machine
but even better alexi radul my graduate
student
two years ago i suppose he got a
doctor's degree uh
made a great breakthrough here the great
breakthrough was
that uh we don't actually put values in
these cells
we put information about a value in a
cell and i'll get to that in later a
little later
what it means is that what a cell
contains is a monotonically increasing
value of information about a value
gets better and better information as a
consequence
things like the synchronization problems
go away
for a parallel machine this becomes a
very powerful
mechanism for building a very
a very a very large complex machine in a
simple way
but it's electrical engineers point of
view it's not a computer science point
of view
it's not data flow okay it's closely
related
but it's not okay it's a very different
kind of thing
because we're worried about information
that's being accumulate in these cells
but let me just go a little further one
of the other problems i hate computer
languages now almost all of them
including the ones i invent
okay and part of the reason is because
they're full of expressions they could
be
even worse they could be statements okay
but they're expressions
and what i mean by that is an expression
expression is a tree
okay and what's going you got a bunch of
values and they only come
go up the tree and they collected about
one output
that's what you want to think about it
and you don't have any names for the
intermediate parts
there's no name for this place or this
place as in the circuit diagrams you
have an electrical circuit
okay and boy those are useful places to
put names on
now sometimes they're a pain in the butt
you've got to be careful not to
not take overwhelmed with names but
indeed yeah
one big difference in this case is i'm
going to
change it so propagators have all all
connections are explicit
they have names so you see this one this
is a this is a step
for the computation of the square root
right you could by
huron's method which is sometimes called
newton's method that was invented
two thousand years earlier by hearing of
alexandria newton did a generalization
which was tremendously important
which is any function but for square
root it was understood by
by huron what you do is you take the
average of the thing you're trying to
take the square root of and the guess
you have for the square root
and you add that to the you take the
ratio of those
add that to the out of the guess you
have and and divide it by two
you make the average of the guess into
the
into the the query uh plus the
plus the guess okay and that converges
to the square root
quadratically that's that's hiron's
method and so that's what this is and so
here
here's a propagator description which is
a wiring diagram
and indeed i have to i'm looking now at
something that looks very much like
again assembly language i've got good
languages for this yet
okay but i'm using lambda glue to put it
together
lambda glue is so excellent for getting
getting going before we understand what
the real language is
okay um so here we have here we have
cells that we're making up which are all
the intermediate ones this takes three
cells as inputs and it says
if i want to uh divide x by g i put the
result in the x over g
cell and divide i add g to x over g and
put the result into the g plus x over g
cell and so on and that's what that is
okay so you're seeing
a little wiring diagram for little
machines
imagine each of these things is our
autonomous machine running continuously
if i can burn processor i can do that
right supposing i have as much processor
as i had memory
for proposing i had for every for every
little memory module i had i had a big
processor associated with it
don't worry about that that'll happen
it's going to happen
because there's no other way to make the
future happen okay
so of course this works as you expect
you get a better guess
but now you can also make an iterative
wiring diagram view of the world
okay what are we seeing here what we're
seeing is
of course a machine a wiring time for a
machine the machine is potentially
infinite
because it's got a copy of itself right
there inside of itself
right it's got the huron step in it the
machine inside of it of course
okay but this is a this is a way to
think about things which is quite
different
okay turns out things may have multiple
outputs okay
this none of the ones here do but things
may have multiple outputs for example
the way you divide integers you get the
quotient and the remainder
okay that's it why why have to do one or
the other
and why not even think about that as
being the normal way to think
most processes have that property or
what if you have things which have
many things that go in and many go out
but in any case
okay we have wiring diagrams like this
and of course
the way in which this guy squared energy
knows whether or not to expand himself
that's a
implementation question is a question
like
the difference between applicative water
and normal order in calculus lambda
calculus are you choosing to
expand something when you all the inputs
are there or only one input or
you want the output or anything like
that that's a different question
okay i'm not going to worry about that
right now okay we can make machines do
it any way we like
and we can have policies that can be
can be can be allow you to do both
remember a real engineer
doesn't want just a religion about how
to solve a problem
like object oriented or functional or
imperative
or logic programming this piece of the
problem wants to be a
functional program this piece of the
program wants to be imperative this
piece wants to be object oriented and
guess what this piece wants to be
logically based
and they all want to work together
youthfully and
because of the way that the problem is
structured
whatever it is and i want i don't want
to think that there's any correct answer
to any of those it would be awful bad
writing
writing writing a device driver in a
functional language
it would be awful bad writing anything
like a symbolic manipulator
in a thing with complicated syntax it's
awful bad to write a to write a uh
what's good a new numerical pro a
numerical program
in in anything but fortran
okay that's a joke i actually
fortunate fortune is a wonderful
language in some ways it's the ancestor
of the wall besides lisp
fortunately the two oldest languages
that still can have anybody using them
and i think that they are the keys to
everything else
the current version of languages okay
but let me go further hey what do we
what can you do with these propagators
and i'm only pushing this idea not
because i think it's the right answer
i'm trying to twist us so we say this is
a different way to think
okay some other we have to think 52
different ways
to fix this problem we haven't i don't
know the answer to how to get out of
this
i don't know how to make a machine that
builds a person out of a cell
okay or but i but i think the problem is
that we've been stuck for too long
thinking about the fact that we've
been diddling with our details we've
been sitting here worrying about our
type system but we ought to be worrying
about how to get flexible machines
and flexible programming so here for
example
um yes okay one thing i could do with
propagating is i can make
i can make constraint propagators out of
directional ones
if i say that look i can make a thing
that will that has an adder
that knows that this is the sum of these
two
which means if it knows these it'll
compute that if it knows these it
computes this
if it knows these it computes this okay
it doesn't matter which the other which
way the the information flows
and in fact i could do that by just
building two
subpropagators which are directional
three of them okay
um multiplication here is a lie
it's actually a little more complicated
because multiplication by zero
has special properties okay
multiplication by zero it doesn't depend
upon the other
argument so this is just for show that
you're seeing here
so it fits on the slide and there are
other things like that
okay but once i can do that of course i
can back make my electricity stuff
because indeed a resist a resistor
really is a two-terminal device
with a constraint that is i times r
equals v
and indeed some other constraints which
is for example the voltage
is the difference of potentials from the
two nodes it's connected to
the current some of the currents into
those terminals is zero
that the product of the current and the
voltage is the power okay and
that that sort of thing okay i can build
that sort of machine
that's you know so i can build up from
what i just showed you
okay so that's nice and it all works
very nicely
but the crucial thing here is what i
said before what mr
radul invented uh two or three years ago
for a doctoral thesis the idea that the
idea that
that the cells merge information
monotonically
so i'm going to tell you the story about
you know the story about if you've got a
barometer
a stopwatch and a ruler how to measure
the height of a building
there are lots of ways of doing that
so here's one thing i could have similar
triangles
okay that is i could have measured i
could put i could say sun is coming in
from the from
from some direction except around here
at this time of the day this day
um and so there's a there's a shadow
cast by the building and a shadow cast
by the uh
by by the uh the barometer if i stand it
on end
so what i can do is if i know that if
i'm a ruler i can measure the barometer
and i can measure its uh
and measure its shadow i can measure the
shadow of the sea of the of the
building if i mark it fast enough so the
sun doesn't move in time and i can
measure it out with the ruler and then i
can compute similar triangles and get
a get a value which is in this case if i
started out with a building that was
i didn't put units in here uh the
building shadow was 50 between 54 feet
0.9 and 55.1 feet long i'm assuming that
that's an interval which is
as error okay and the height of the
barometer is between 0.3 and 0.32 feet
and the shadow of the barometer would be
point three point three six and point
three seven feet
then the building height is is it
drilled between forty four point five
four
one one four and forty eight point nine
seven eight feet
okay that's done by building a similar
triangles propagator which is simple
enough
okay of course i could have done the
other thing i could go to the top of the
building drop the barometer off and see
how long it on the stopwatch it takes to
know you have to click
right that works okay
and if i do that then i can have a four
uh i use
s equal one half a t square whoops okay
that's equal one half eighty square
type propagator and i if i measure the
fall time
i can say i can add that to the system
and i get a building height which is
41. but slightly different okay because
of course measurements differ
they're not the same but i could do
something better
okay i can start out with i can combine
these measurements
okay that is supposing i have i know
that the building shadow is this that's
what i measured with my ruler
and i i measured the barometer's height
and shadow then i dropped the barometer
off the building
and figured out the times okay and so i
got a value there
this is this is a better value uh if i
go down here
if i look but guess what this value let
me go back here a second
the value here is between 41.163 and
47.24
here it is 44. so it's a tighter bounce
but the best thing is that that
information propagates back to the
measurements
hey you know the guy made the
measurement made a slight mistake and we
could find it
okay because each of these measurements
reinforces the others
okay and that's always true in real
science okay
by the way how much time have i taken up
so far
huh 45 so i've got 15 more good okay
thank you but that's i really don't want
to talk more than i'm designed to talk
for 50 minutes
okay i can talk for 60 minutes on any
topic whether or not i know anything
about it
okay so each of these each of these uh
values
is improved from the values we had
before from the ones we measured
okay but you know now we can for example
bribe the superintendent
by giving him the spot watch and we
expect to get the the honest answer out
of this
okay and so we get a value which is not
an interval which is
45 he claims the building's height was
45 okay
okay so we get the content of the
barometer's height now is better still
and all of these are improved
measurements ah
but you know i could do better than that
because in the same way
that you invented these hairy meta
monads to be
allowed to calculus plumbing which is
what they are
they're wonderful stuff by the way but
they are very hairy
uh for people who haven't who haven't
understood that very carefully and
thought about it for a long time so so
in the same way
uh you know you want to be able to carry
extra information with something
what a monad allows you to do is to pipe
around
the value you wish to carry also state
or something like that that's
extra information that gets fed into the
right place
so it's hidden plumbing it can be done
with it's a lambda calculus trick
that most list type programmers knew
about long ago but didn't have a name
for it
and it's very useful to to realize that
it's connected to category theory and
things like that
okay so what do we do here okay
well tracking of provenance okay well
i'm going to attach other information
besides things like
like units and dimensions and stuff like
that i want to carry
with it where information came from so i
can make arguments as to what
where does it come from you saw that in
the in the electrical circuit case
that's very helpful when you're
debugging a complicated problem
okay so let's see what that is
all right well we're going to start
again okay i'm now going to add to
i'm going to make my values be what i
call contingent values
okay so this value which i'm putting in
the building shadow
is a contingent value which is based on
a premise called shadow
it could be several premises which why
there's a list there and i'm assuming
it's a symbol
right now but the premises are they have
no no interesting structure they can
tell whether or not two of them are the
same
okay so these are all shadow shadow
premises
and i get answers which are contingent
on in
on the shadow oops
okay i can do the same thing with the
fall time
okay but this one i'm going to make
dependent upon the
uh upon a premise i call time
the building height now is continued on
both the time and the shadow
okay i if the authority the super gives
me an authoritative result
okay then i can look at the building
height
okay it's dependent upon the say he gave
me that information
but the barometer site is now dependent
on three things
the superintendence estimate the time
estimate and the shadow estimate
but the building shadow estimate is
solely on the shadow estimate and the
fall time
however has been improved by the
superintendent's estimate but not the
other one because the other one wasn't
very interesting
it was superseded the information is
monotonically increasing in each of
these in each of these
cells okay the monotonic increase is
crucial
that one way to do that kind of thing of
course is with things like intervals but
imagine you had
unification algorithm for example that's
a way of
combining information and there are lots
of things like that
right suppose i have a free a
transformative signal
approximate and i have the a time domain
for an approximate version of the signal
both with noise
can combine let's get better estimates
of what that is
so now here's a this gives us even more
power
because what i'm going to do is assume
that of course information is usually
inconsistent almost all the
information in my head is inconsistent i
believe lots of things that are false
right we all do right
but the important thing is that i can i
don't fall apart every time i think is
the famous robot in some
in some science fiction story okay why
it's because
if i run into one of these
inconsistencies i giggle
okay that's the answer it's a it's
because i can keep apart
locally consistent subsystems of my
thinking
and each of those i can make the
deductions that i know where they come
from
i hope and they're dependent only on the
things that i
that i specify so they look at this for
a sec
for example again i'm now going to make
these things called tms's
truth maintenance systems they were
invented
again originally partly by stallman and
me
but they were given a name by john doyle
who was one of my graduate students
who wrote a master's thesis about them
his phd this was about something else
and david mcallister did some work on
them
and made another version of it and then
there was a whole book by two of my
former students
uh johan de clear and and ken forbus
which is called building problem solvers
which is pretty much about truth
maintenance systems
okay so there's a whole is a whole nice
thing what it is is it's a collection of
facts
okay with appropriate dependencies such
that it's possible to say what is the
best estimate you can give me
of the consequences of these facts the
logical or anything else
and so in every cell i'm going to put a
truth maintenance system instead
which is a thing that's going to
maintain the best estimates of what's
going on
with the ability to back out okay
so here's what you're seeing here is
that sort of thing
and indeed uh i can i can do all the
standard things
you saw here okay and i'm not going to
go through this but if you look at
what's inside the building height at the
end
of this little sequence there's a three
possible contingencies depending upon
different dependencies
okay and uh this can grow quite large
but it doesn't grow very large because
anything which is subsumed
by some other deduction goes away
and eventually we can do things like now
change our point of view
i can i can change my world view i can
bring in like let's see go back here
where's the cat
i can decide that i could i want to kick
out the time
yes supposedly i want to kick out the
the time measurement
i want to decide that wasn't so good
well i can get a value for the building
height which is dependent only on the
shadow map whoops shadow measurement
i could bring back the time measurement
and kick out the shadow measurement and
i've got the something that depends on
the time measurement okay if i
if i if i add the superintendent stuff
in and i bring in the shadow measurement
i get something else i can decide i
don't really like the time measurement
and i i get the dependence i get the
result it depends only on those two
okay and i can walk this thing around a
lot
okay that's a lot of fun but better than
that i can get contradictions
maybe somebody made a mistake maybe
there's a lie
maybe the superintendent's a liar okay
or maybe
the the the the the ruler where was it
was not held quite right quite right
when i measured the
height of the whatever okay look in real
scientific stuff
supposing i have a corpus of of all the
medical
material in the world all the journals
you know darn well that most of the
most of the uh articles are wrong okay
and there's a good reason for that
the reason is that that people do for
experiments with p less than .05
okay that's the um they
that their measure of whether or not
something is good is a good experiment
is whether or not the chance of being
wrong is one in 20.
okay now since they do far more than 20
experiments
and they only publish the ones that come
out positive okay
you can you make your deduction from
that there's great papers about this so
by ionitis there's a great paper
about about why almost all medical
research is wrong
um and that's but you know we still live
better than we did 50 years ago so it
can't be completely true
but in any case you know if a physicist
walks in with b less than 0.05
they're thrown out of the room it's
gotta be p less than 10 to my seventh or
something for anybody to be interested
okay um anyway so here we go
uh here we hear what i'm gonna look at a
contradiction the contradiction depended
upon
the superintendent of the pressure
measurement i was measuring this one ah
i used the barometer a second time maybe
i had two barometers
okay so i'm getting back here and i
measured the measured that by
a pressure measurement which i suppose i
didn't put on the on the screen
which of course you know the difference
in the pressure from the knife as you
move
right over up and down the building is
going to be the weight of air between
those two
okay and so so i got a contradiction
between those two
and i can decide which of those i like
or don't like as you can see here
okay or here okay i get two different
different values so i can maintain an
inconsistent world view
a major incident world view by having
locally consistent world views
ah but better okay
yes even better
i can also have the machine
automatically find for me
the consistent sub consistent sub
the sub world views that are consistent
but world view is consistent
that's called dependency directed
backtracking and unlike
chronological backtracking which you
would get say by using the sequence
monad
uh and a failure mode right for those of
you who are
pascalites okay that would give you a
chronological backtrack
unlike that i can do much much more
efficient backtracking because i know
the provenance is very fact so i could
say if this
if i got a contradiction here okay and
i've got another contradiction
and the intersection is this guy it's
highly probably probably he's the bad
but bad guy
but even so if i just find something to
rule out
okay i can rule out a whole sub tree
without having to undo anything and redo
it
redo uh computations when that were
already
correct okay because they but they were
chronologically later
okay remember this because a parallel
machine in principle it's right now
simulated serially of course by a little
time sharing system
but parallel machine with with uh with
where all of these things are
independently looking at information and
carrying them from place to the next
okay so here's an example of the famous
uh
famous story uh there's a five-story
building baker cooper fletcher miller
and smith live on one of the five floors
okay uh i require that uh baker cooper
fletcher miller and smith live on
distinct floors
that baker is not on the fifth floor
cooper is not on the first fletcher is
not on the fifth fletcher is not in the
first miller's on a higher floor than
cooper
and uh the and the the
smith and fletcher and fletcher cooper
are are not on adjacent floors
okay and i want to know what the answer
is and it's pretty easy to get
the number of quotes and it's very very
efficient if i did this by
by a chronological process this would be
3 000 or something backtracks
to investigate this space
not that search is a good thing search
is always exponential
and will always eat you if you let it so
this is not to say that we should be
doing search
it's just showing that i can
automatically find consistent subsystems
of a complex system because this is this
is working by backtracking on
consistency inconsistencies
okay now let me tell you go back to the
original thing i was talking about at
the beginning
okay when i was an undergraduate at mit
i used to walk by jerry letterman's land
everybody who jerry levin was
who does okay everybody remember here
with the lebanon leary debates
debate or anything like he was a famous
neurophysiologist
who was the first person to measure uh
potentials from neurons
and he did he made great amplifiers he
was professor of
electrical engineering uh and biology
and humanities at mit okay and uh i
used to go by his lab which said
laboratory of experimental histology
yes i was i was employed as minsky one
of minsky's computer hackers
okay so i would go over there and i
passed by the leftist lab and i dropped
in and listened and talked about
wonderful things about neurophysiology
and things like that and one thing that
ledman
he died by the way last year uh one
thing that uh
he would explain or explain quite often
is that almost all the cells
in in the central nervous system are
very tiny much tinier than the ones that
you hear that have long axons and things
like that
and you can't it's really hard to see
them even with a good microscope
and it's pretty hard to it's pretty hard
to uh measure potentials from them
action potentials and things like that
so he he he had
this idea that they actually are
unbelievable as being undercounted
that they may be hypothesis many of
these neurons
do not explicitly are not explicitly
directional
that they are actually things that are
like these constraints
that feel a bunch of other things and
adjust adjust the sensitivity
of other neurons they touch okay
so if they say gee i feel these three
things be doing something can i say
let me make this guy do something too
okay but if it's only these two
then i better make this guy do something
and leave this one alone or inhibit this
one
okay that was the kind of idea he had
which might be false i'm not trying to
suggest it's true or false
i don't know i don't know anything about
neurophysiology okay
but except for what i've learned by
walking into london's lab
but oh yes he could talk about any so
i could talk about it for an hour too
sure
but getting back to the kinesis triangle
illusion
is it possible is it possible
that almost all the computation that we
see that's really fast
is filling in details
what is going on in that electrical
circuit example i showed you even with a
big circuit it's filling in details
that the diagram is a memory and i'm
writing in specific well-known defined
places the answers that i can deduce
from local
information okay
sometimes i have to invent a variable
and propagate it around get an equation
but i hope not very often okay but most
of the time i'm doing
by picking my models correctly i'm
choosing to make the
problem simple enough so i can do this
kind of propagation
which fills in details what's happening
here what's happening here
is this guy is giving me evidence that
there's something
that there's something including this
black circle
by golly there's good evidence here that
this black triangle is being included by
something too
okay maybe there's good evidence that's
a good enough evidence to think that
maybe there's a white thing that
connects these
okay and things like that and maybe
that's done by
some magic process that looks something
like that for all we know
okay i don't know this is true i don't
claim it's true
okay it's different way to think maybe
it's worth
investigating it might be completely
nonsense
on the other hand we have to throw away
our current ways of thinking if we ever
expect to solve these problems
so in summary okay i'm claiming
the problem uh facing us as computer
engineers
is not correctness it's evolvability
a trivial example of making things more
evolvable
is that an extensible generic operations
may help
because they allow us to extend
functions without modification but they
make proofs very difficult
a more radical proposal is maybe there
are freedoms that we can unlock
unlock by throwing away our idea of
architecture
okay how machines have to work here's
one
particular example which is concurrent
and parallel in an essential way
it's redundant and degenerate meaning
it's possible to compute the
same thing many times and put them into
the same place and it doesn't cause any
trouble
except if one of the things dies you get
to say the correct answer another way
it could be degenerate means i can
compute a different way
the same way i can compute in my physics
class by
newton's newton's uh vector vector
uh methods i can compute uh the motion
of something like the planets
okay i can compute it by the lagrangian
method i can compute it by the
hamiltonian method they get the same
answer but they get they
reveal different phenomena
i'm not going to find out about how the
symmetries in the system correspond to
the
correspond to the um conserved
quantities if i look at newton's method
okay that's why i want to use lagranges
if i want to do a canonical
transformation it better be hamiltonian
okay so there are all these that's what
degeneracy means
many ways of doing something if i can't
eat the
sugar because i'm screwed up in some way
okay then i can get my calories out of
out of proteins every biological system
has many ways of doing things
that's called degeneracy okay i can
maintain providence as i can know where
data comes from
and follow it around and combine the
data combines i can combine the
provenances appropriately sometimes you
have to subtract
as in a conditional proof if you say
assume a get conclude b
therefore you can conclude a implies b
without the assumption of a
so there are certain kinds of rules that
have to delete the provenance
when they do it but you have to know
that so the means of combining
provenance
they have to be taken care of okay and i
can tell you about dependency directed
backtracking which is a useful way
of of controlling controlling
non-deterministic search sometimes
okay that's an example of a of things
that i'm just pushing forward
as being a possible way to break out but
i want to hear every way that can
and that's all i have to say today okay